previously on TV sins look local woman I
know that you hold me up as your career
template and it gives you some sort of
charge to challenge me but give it a
rest
so if a photon is directed through a
plane with two slits in it and either
slit is observed will not go through
both slits can we use new terminology
the word slit makes me uncomfortable in
my moist areas hang on one across is
Aegean eight down is Nabokov thirty
seconds in and the characters have
alienated me with their intellect and
manners toward puzzled ears also I get
that Leonard is supposed to be clever in
all but I missed the part where we were
told he has the ability to speed read
from a Dutch angle also also what kind
of crossword puzzle is Althea working on
no wonder she's stuck meanwhile I'm over
here trying to figure out seventeen down
Garfield's favorite pan dish invented in
Italy that rhymes with piranha hmm maybe
it would be excellent at TV since I have
a sister with the same basic DNA mix who
hostesses at Fuddruckers that's fun
racist what if she winds up with a
toddler who doesn't know if he should
use an integral or a differential to
solve the area under a curve as someone
who doesn't know the difference Ellucian
for an areola Kirk or whatever you just
said I can assure you I'm fine elitist
nerds got a rage I guess what's the
protocol for leaving I don't know I've
never reneged on a proffer of sperm
before well you wouldn't let her because
in the proffer e would be the one
presenting for acceptance the second
party would be the one choosing to stay
relieved new neighbor wouldn't she have
heard a male voice coming from the hall
just ten feet away
significant improvement over the old
neighbor 200-pound transvestite with a
skin condition yes she is aa 2007 a year
that sounds like we were in a
progressive time but clearly were also
after this creepy encounter defying all
laws of social boundaries they not only
all become friends but I saw YouTube
clip where two of them actually get
married I have a very wide circle I have
two hundred and twelve friends on
MySpace MySpace just put in my brain do
you want me to move well sit somewhere
else
penny perplexes me she boldly enters a
stranger's home eats their food sits in
their seat and when I accidentally
fast-forwarded I saw her in the shower
this is a story of Goldilocks also in
real life if someone is adamant about
having a seat in their own home the
other person moves without question if
only two people live here then why are
there three portions do they always buy
an extra to split later is a further
apartment ghost this was a plot
convenience wasn't it damn it
Leonard can't process corn fun fact
humans in general can't process corn
well technically we can digest part of
it but our body doesn't have the
bacteria necessary to digest the
cellulose of the pericarp look at me
flexing my nerd knowledge now who's the
nerd nerd I'm all gross for moving my
stupid shower doesn't even work
shower works laugh tracks are like audio
herpes the laughter spreads through the
episode into places that it should not
go and it makes me itchy irritable and
short would be totally weird if I used
it yes no no no no yes these men are
strangers you are in a strange home and
this is a bad idea also is this one of
those old penthouse letters come to life
two nerds just happened upon a new
beautiful neighbor who just happens to
keep her door open so they could meet
her and she's insanely nice and now she
has no problem taking a shower in a
stranger's apartment the way this is
progressing a threesome is coming up
right now I know why this is called the
Big Bang Theory it's right down the hall
you're going to shower now without any
of your own toiletries or towels who
does that it has been some time since
we've had a woman take our clothes off
in our apartment that's not true
remember Thanksgiving my grandmother
with episode just a reminder this was
the number-one sitcom on television for
over ten years
this beverage was just opened and his
missing liquid do you know how
concerning that is probably contaminated
and these two are caught up thinking
about a naked woman in the shower
getting all sudsy probably using their
loofah and dripping and hot steamy water
and wait what was I talking about do you
think this possibility will be helped or
hindered when she discovers your luke
skywalker no more tears Shampoo star
fader shampoo i just raged search the
internet for Luke Skywalker shampoo and
found nothing as for the dark shampoo it
may have existed in the 80s or 90s which
means Leonard's shampoos 20-some years
old which is almost as discussing is
using a product that is now a
collectible Herbal Essences where's the
Darth Vader shampoo I demand to see this
product do you think with your penis
that's a biological impossibility and
you didn't have to come that's a
possibility that the writers were 2/3 of
the way to a great double entendre but
I'm guessing it's just a coincidence so
so you guys work with Leonard and
Sheldon at the University
good god they're still eating that food
from them picking it up to this point at
least an hour has passed or more and
everyone's going to be violently ill as
all insane also why isn't she wet her
hair and makeup look the exact same my
college girlfriend didn't remove her
before she showered she came out looking
like a raccoon had a baby with a sea
monster
penny looks like a daisy I'm sorry do
you speak English
you my apologies what's your plan it's
just a privilege to watch your mind you
are well that's possible there are more
insulting quirks to the character of
Sheldon Cooper than I will ever be aware
of it should not go oh no tiss that Jim
Parsons gives his all to this role and
never once breaks the seal of creepy
genius for 12 seasons I'm feeling
generous enough to knock a scent off to
that Manny's hallway plants look like
borderline weapons I'm envisioning one
drunken night from a couple of tenants
an innocent invite to plant jousting and
multiple eyeballs falling on the floor
can't be said enough that tidy whities
are a sin why don't you put some clothes
on I'll get my purse and dinner is on me
okay thank you I know most people cite
how this show is about nerds and nerdy
things but there's also so many photo
situations it's a wonder the latter
seasons warn about half the characters
suffering from obesity and maybe a
couple cases of diabetes you're not done
with her are you
not for let's see 281 episodes episode
does not contain an Amy Farrah Fowler 30
Q possible and codings normally you'd
use a computer to run all these
combinations but it was quickly just to
do it longhand Tommy how's the beeping I
have a board if you like boards this is
my board
[Music]
Sheldon sit sit Ubu sit
good dog Oh Shantay Mademoiselle can I
borrow your towel for a sec my car just
hit a water buffalo hangout maybe go on
a quest do you wanna play a game